Hello大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿
放心說 我是周慕姿心理師
今天又邀請到我們最喜歡的鐘穎老師
Hello各位聽眾好
每次鐘穎老師來啊
那個不管是YT也好還是Podcast
我那個收聽率都特別高
然後大家都對榮格非常有興趣
所以我們現在看到鐘穎老師
就會重疊起那個榮格的臉
哈哈哈
所以我們今天呢一樣又要來談榮格
但是呢除了談榮格之外
我們還是先恭喜鐘穎老師
帶來他的新書
對感謝 《活出你的本來面目》
這真的很讚欸
所以其實因為鐘穎老師在自己的
就是愛智者書窩
的就是FB上
其實常常分享很多包含個體化
跟就是我們到底要怎麼找尋自我
的一些內容
這一次看到這個題目
就感覺到很像是老師在講那個個體化
我們怎麼知道自己是什麼樣子
然後呢要怎麼活出自己的樣子
所以這一次的主題
就是比較偏向類似這樣子的 內容嗎
對對對是想要用
用這句話來表達榮格心理學的
我認為的核心觀念
就是活出你的本來面目
嗯他其實跟我們的禪宗啊
其實是有一點聯繫的
那可能很多聽眾朋友不曉得
榮格本人啊
他自己也形容他自己的心理學叫做禪
嗯問他說
如果只用一個字來形容你的心理學
你會選用哪一個
他就說禪
所以榮格本人其實是一個非常東方
非常中國的一個心理學家
好他的那個思想的血液裡面啊
流有這個東方的這個血液
可是我那時候接觸榮格心理學
一開始接觸其實赫赫隼雄哦
我非常非常喜歡他的作品
然後所以在看
就是鐘穎老師在寫榮格
就是他是很禪的這個部分
所以我其實覺得非常有趣
因為榮格是一個雖然他在講心理學
雖然他的訓練背景其實是醫師背景
那醫師背景我們的想像就是
尤其是在國外
他們的一開始訓練
醫師背景都是非常實證科學的
那我們常常就是做了
這些實證科學訓練
之後才轉
就是心理分析相關的一些工作
然後其實這兩個部分是差非常多的
因為像我先生
他病理科
然後他有時候在看我念的東西
他就說所以證據在哪裡
就是他就會常常問
然後我就可能會跟他分享
他說所以你們真的是很質化研究欸
因為
我們好像早期受到什麼樣的訓練之後
我們很容易會講話
其實在剛好在那個
就是鐘穎老師這本書裡面也有提到
就是我們有時候會非常兩極的
只抓一個
我們很習慣
跟很舒服的一個方式去生活
去工作可是可能就會造成
就是
不管是各式各樣的一些困難或問題
那榮格在這方面彈性很大
我不知道
鐘穎老師怎麼看這個部分
好了這個榮格本人呢
他自己在這個接受西方的訓練
還有他自己對這個內在的
心理世界的這個觀察
其實兩個取向落差很大
他自己在面對這個衝突的時候
這個衝突其實很慣著他一生啊
聽說他是他一生啊
所以如果呃
現代人在讀這本書的時候啊
或者說您也在受到這個西方訓練
可是你的 你對生命的理解
有一種直覺的層次
直觀的層次
一種不同於西方社會
科學理念的那個層次
你所遭遇到的這種痛苦跟撕裂感
其實我相信很多人都有
榮格本人也都經歷過
所以榮格本人他的從他的自傳
還有從他的整個學科的演變
都可以發現
他其實一直處於很大的一個衝突中
如果或者說他很努力的
把他內在所驚艷到的那些世界
用一個比較科學的方式來表達他
那其實這也是榮格心理學
對我們來說會很吸引人的一個原因啊
因為榮格心理學之所以會紅
很大原因是因為我們在一
般的民俗的世界裡面
會看到很多特別的現象
比如說附身 嗯 卡到陰
那比如說這個心靈感應啊
那比如說幽浮飛碟
這樣這樣的一個現象啊
或者甚至大家比較熟悉的占卜算命
這樣的一個行為
好像除了榮格心理學以外
沒有其他的
這個心理學可以普遍性的啊
一次性的去說明這些所有的現象
那這些現象
一直以來都是榮格所關注的重點
當他關注這些事物的時候
試圖去得到的
是這個他背後所共通的心理學原理
所以我覺得慕姿
去分享您跟您先生之間
這兩種不同觀點的這種碰撞啊
其實榮格心理學
也非常的凸顯
他自己本人是不太舒服的
那如果你也曾經有過這樣的不舒服啊
其實也蠻適合來讀一讀這本書
如果你今天就是
鐘穎老師一開始就先講到這個衝突
然後我覺得其實所有的心理學
就是不管任何學派
當然我覺得榮格他最酷的地方
就是他可以去處理一些
我們一般心理科學比較難去
就是跨足的一些領域
包含他用一個很簡單的詞
就會讓我們某方面得到一個安慰
叫做共識性嘛
就是遇到什麼事
然後我們通常都說任何事情
就是哦那可能就是一個一個狀態
但榮格用了一個共時性
去討論這個部分
然後我覺得這個東西就有點
他其實就一些玄妙在裡面
對所以我我我覺得比較有趣就是
榮格他在這個部分上
他還是企圖
用一個比較就是科學的方式
他不是用非常非常的
真的到靈性到的程度
所以讓大家覺得要靠近這個這個部分
他還是有一個脈絡跟結構可以跟隨
那我比較好奇的是
就是如果鐘穎老師來看
就是榮格他在講這個
我們因為我們的衝突
其實幾乎是我們人類想要找尋
我們想要認識內心
然後想想
要知道我們內心發生什麼事
的一個很大根源
如果是以榮格的這個學派來說
或是這本書來說
最想第一個想要跟大家分享那個衝突
是不是就是陰影
對
我想多數人之所以認識榮格心理學
應該也跟陰影這個概念有關
那陰影的概念
我們簡單的來說
就是所有我不認識的事物都是陰影
那如果這個這句話還不好懂
我再換個方式
所有讓你情動的都是陰影
這個情動是你的情緒有動搖
那就兩大類嘛
第一個是讓我喜歡的
讓我有欲求的
比如說我在追求平靜
我在追求舒適啊
在追求親子關係的和諧
情動啊那第二就是我所憎惡的
我討厭的東西
讓我不舒服
我希望他趕快遠離的
那些各種煩惱和內耗
其實這兩類的來源
讓我們行動的
它的背後
應該都跟我們的陰影有所關聯
它反應的是我們內心有一個需求
這個需求會讓我們誤以為
我必須從外面才能得到它
或擁有它
那榮格心理學提醒是
當你有情動的時候
你要注意它的源頭其實在內在
不是在外面
其實他的這個說法跟佛教就非
常非常的接近
所有讓你不舒服的事物
你覺得可以得到的幸福
都沒有辦法從外面得來
所以你要皈依你的心
那我覺得榮格心理學在這一點
其實就非常跟東方是很接近的
嗯
我我剛剛在聽老師講這個東西的時候
我不知道為什麼就想到
因為我們最近我們今天錄音的時候
最近剛好出現一個很
就是很紅的新聞啊
已經延燒好多天了
到現在都還在討論
就是那個節運上
就是就是有一個就是婆婆
就是跟人家要
就是博愛座讓位
就被一個年輕人就是踹了一腳的
這個部分
就你會發現
這個新聞
很多人產生很多反應
就是不管是看到這個年輕人踹了一腳
或是看到這個婆婆的行動
然後甚至就有些人可能就會發現這個
他也被這個婆婆就是侵犯過界限啊
或是被很不合理的對待啊等等的
就是這些東西
不知道
如果用陰影的這個角度來看這件事情
鐘穎老師會怎麼看
這個新聞
為什麼會引發我們整個台灣社會
這麼多的
就是情緒跟感受
幾乎每個人都會有一些感覺
跟有一些想要表達的東西
嗯確實這個新聞發生之後
網絡上顯然有兩派的看法了
一派好像是在說
我們是不是走入了厭老社會
那用報以暴制暴是對的嗎
這是一派
那第二派當然會覺得
私法正義
這私人的私啊
私法正義的執行啊
所以這個如果真的是被罰
了那18,000塊
那就大家一起
來這個來募資
哈哈哈大家一起募資
幫把這個罰款給繳掉啊
就是說認為這個道理是對的啊
或者是錯的
那其實社會議題
很容易勾出我們內心的一些
沒有被滿足的情緒
或者是未完成的情節
應該這麼說
就說如果我覺得這個社會的公義
沒有依照我想像的被落實
那麼我在這個世界裡面
我看到的
我的立場
就會比較像是支持那位年輕人
那位年輕的同學
那位同學好像好像我認識
哈哈哈對對對
然後呢這個
另外一個是
這個如果您的剛好是相反啊
你看到是一個更
你希望看到的是一個更有序的
有秩序的
一個所謂的我們可以以語言的溝通
或是以避害避難為最優先價值的人
那麼你看到了
可能就會覺得
你會想要去譴責這個行為
因為這個行為本身
不僅讓這個社會更秩序
同時也肯讓當事人
這個帶來更多的麻煩啊
所以
他以避難避害這樣的一個觀點去看
內心
其實可能都勾動我們早期的一些事件
我們怎麼被教啊
然後我們怎麼理解這個世界
這個世界回饋哪些東西給我們
而他藏在我們未知的地方
所以我很好奇
如果是用陰影的角度來看
我們在看到那一個就是年輕人
踹那一腳
會覺得哎呦
雖然是那個對方也是有點不合理的
但是哩阿捏馬
母湯啦
就是不要以暴制暴
或者是看到那個婆婆她會用她個人的
就是不管是年紀也好
會不會 聽起來
就是她好像從年輕就長這樣
所以跟她年紀可能也沒什麼關係
她會比較容易的
就是去想要獲得主控權
他在任何地方他都要
就是得到他的權益
甚至他不不惜侵犯別人的權益
他想要這個東西
他就是要他沒有同理心
他不考慮別人的立場
這兩個狀態如果是
就陰影的角度來看
鐘穎老師覺得我們看到這兩個狀態
會有不同的在乎點
那跟我們內心的什麼陰影有關
就是例如說我看到那個年輕人這樣子
我就會覺得啊不要以暴制暴
我的陰影可能會是什麼
然後當我今天看到那個就是那個婆婆
他又剛好是一個年紀比較大
你就是要讓給老年人的
這些就是規矩的這些東西
我們看到這個東西
他就覺得說為什麼
憑什麼一定要人家這樣
你又不是沒有別的選擇
等等這些
可能我們的各自對應到內心的陰影
會是什麼
陰影裡面的內容很多
那榮格也常常說
情節很可能是接近於無限的
所以我們可以給他很多很多名字
那我們大致可以猜啊
如果我比較同情那位年輕人
那我猜我們那背後被拉出來的
很可能跟救世主情節比較
受害者情節比較相關
因為我覺得他被那個婆婆連續兩次
你可以說攻擊
是用一個無禮的方式請他起來
但我不太敢去徵求我的權
那我身為一個受害者
益的時候啊
有人幫我踢了一腳
我打了一拳
就是替代性的那個情緒
對對對對對
我可能不敢做
但是我看到你可以做
我的感受會就是不一樣
嗯對那如果是覺得 哎呦
年輕人就是太衝動了
就是這樣子
是厭老啊 什麼什麼的
那可能他內在的陰影
可能會是哪一個方向
本來會是那個受害者的對立面
可能
引發的是比較聖母心或救世主的情節
是覺得
說這個社會的秩序應該
或者人性的關懷
應該高於我個人的權益的受損
是她今天是一位老太太
那你坐的位置
是所謂的優先座或是博愛座
那其實你就應該發揮某一種
讓這個秩序能夠變得更好的心理
去產生某種行為
特別你也說
你看捷運上面還有其他的位置
你可以離開這個位置
把這個位置讓給他
你坐到其他的位置去
是那
聽起來其實好像也有一點
像是權威情節的一種反動
對對對就是我遇到權威的時候
有時候我會不會比較習慣性
就是如果為了這個秩序
為了這個社會
我可能還是選一個不要不要起衝突的
然後呢反正就是
我的權益只是稍稍的有一點點受損
我的個人意志只是稍稍的有些受損
但是我們的關係
就是這個社會的秩序
仍然可以因為我個人小小的受損
而有一些
繼續運作
然後所以這個部分就會是
是不是有點像權位情節的
一個一個
有可能
它反映出來的東西可能不一樣
雖然他說出來東西可能會類似
但是真的
同一個行為的背後的動機是不同的
沒錯
所以其實這個部分也想跟大家分享
就有的時候
可能大家會提出不一樣的意見跟行動
或是一樣的意見跟行動
可是我們在乎的事情可能不太一樣
所以有可能在聽我我們在跟
就是特別像這個大家都知道的事件
然後聽到我跟鐘穎老師在說
他可能講說可是我不是這樣想啊
我雖然是這個看法
可是我的理由是什麼
非常合理
因為你會有不同的動機
我們的確沒有辦法全部都猜的到
但我剛剛在聽
因為我那時候在讀這本書
在講到陰影的部分時候
我就想起我自己有一個例子
然後我也是想問問鐘穎老師
有沒有
就是慢慢的在接受陰影的過程
變化的例子
我也想問問鐘穎老師
因為我自己以前剛開始
就是開始從事諮商工作
然後後來就是開諮商所啊
然後可能有比較多工作
跟責任在自己身上
就我
我覺得那個時候的我是很嚴厲的
意思就是
我覺得我很容易會被
怎麼樣是一個好心理師
這一類的議題勾動情緒
比如說看到不合理的
別的心理師的一些行動啦
或者是說
在工作上跟我一起合作的夥伴
如果他們沒有
就是足夠的注重
比如說個案的權益啊
或是忽略什麼事情啊
我發現我那個時候的情緒
都會大很多
然後還有就是
就是包含那種
其實有點像是剛開始念諮商都會講
心理師怎麼可以這樣
一定要怎麼樣
就那個時候會有一個潔癖情節這樣子
然後很很有趣的是
我後來慢慢意識到這件事情
然後我開始一直在問我自己
為什麼我這麼害怕
如果不做到什麼這樣子就不對或不好
為什麼我會對這些事情這麼生氣
就是以前就是會直接出去嘛
後來就會花比較多時間去想
說為什麼這件事情對我這麼重要
那也不是說他不能是重要
因為我們還是要有一點羞恥心
不然這樣子也是不能工作
可是我的意思是
為什麼這是發生在別人身上的事情
我會心情我的情緒會這麼大
因為不管如何
只要我試著想要說他這樣是不對的
這其實就是一個分辨
我自己就在做一個分辨
意思我跟他不一樣
就是我在做一個自我定義的過程
不管我有沒有跟人家說
所以我後來發現
那其實某方面是我好像就是我的陰影
雖然我那時候沒有真的這麼意識
然後我覺得蠻有趣的地方是
當我開始越來越發現這件事情之後
我就發現我越來越不嚴格
哈哈哈
我說我越來越不嚴格不代表說我不會
我不會對自己有一些要求
那個部分沒有太大的改變
可是我覺得比較大的改變是
我看到別人的一些行動的時候
我變得比較沒有那麼多的評論跟情緒
我覺得這件事情很有趣
所以我也想問問鐘穎老師的看法
剛剛慕姿心理師分享的
其實我聽起來比較像
接近是人格面具的問題
哦
我覺得這就是很有趣
就是說
當我們一開始真的剛畢業的年輕人
或我們剛獲得某一種專業身份是
我們會很認同這個專業身份
也就說我們急著把這個面具跟我
我中意這個人畫上等號
我是心理師
他是心理師或他是醫師等等
那經過一段時間
我們就會覺得
因為我跟這個面具黏的很緊
自然
我們也會很嚴格的用這張人格面具
去看待另外一個擁有相同面具的同行
可是
剛剛這個慕姿也分享一個很有趣的事
是當我們自己慢慢的
能夠把面具跟我自己分開的時候
當我有覺察
哎我為什麼要這麼做呢
當我開始跟他有覺察有分開
人會變得寬容
嗯我覺得人年輕的時候
其實真的有個傾向
傾向我要把我活成人格面具的樣子
傾向我覺得
別人也必須活成人格面具的樣子
7-11的店員看到我進來說
歡迎光臨
是!@#$#啊還是歡迎光臨啊
這個念的太
他這個態度我就會給很介意啊
這個警察這個騎著公務車去買便當
我就會去想要把他拍照下來啊
然後拿去公審啊
我覺得警察怎麼可以吃便當
因為我希望他的人格面具是
就是很尊很很威嚴
對
就覺得你是不是在偷懶啊
或者說老師挖鼻孔好像就不適合啊
那一樣嘛
就什麼所謂
的很流行說的長女病
媽媽女兒好像都必須有某一種樣子
也因為這樣
其實很多時候我們不太
對自己的父母好像不太諒解
因為我們好像也在要求我們的父母
一定
把你爸媽的那個面具做好
給你老娘帶好
哈哈哈對
那其實當我們慢慢來到一個年紀
我發現
其實自己可能跟我們的面具本身
有一個距離
我怎麼樣也達不到面具的要求時候
人會變寬容
那這個歷程也可能是伴隨著
我開始回頭看
什麼東西勾起了我
這可能就是陰影
那個陰影的內容很可能是指人格面具
嗯對
所以聽起來其實陰影連接到人格面具
其實很容易會發生的事情
因為剛光這樣講
人格面具陰影
甚至我們剛前面提的權威情節
這個東西
其實很容易混在一起
因為如果今天我越 例如說我權威情節
我對我的我對權威是越肯定的
我是越覺得這這個社會是應該要權威
我在自己成為一個權威
也就是我的人格面具
是一個權威的時候
我的態度跟我的的狀況
我就會越需要扮演這個角色
扮演的可圈可點
然後我就會越看不起
不是這樣子扮演的人
或者我就會希望旁邊的人這樣扮演
特別是如果我在這一個扮演這個這個
這個人格面具的時候
我必須犧牲很多東西
我看到那些不犧牲東西我就會很氣嘛
像有些婆婆媳婦熬成婆有沒有
為什麼我以前當媳婦這麼辛苦
你們現在當媳婦這麼爽之類的
就會有很多情緒
所以這一種情緒的的部分
在榮格上
它會有一個可以支撐的狀態嗎
像我自己就會開玩笑講
說這個算是一個
就是情緒勒索
是一種就是情感的
抓交替嘛就是我以前有被虧待
然後這個虧待呢
我沒有辦法好好的去照顧跟理解
然後我又很認同這個社會主流價值
這個權威
他們的一些規矩跟概念
所以如果回到那個榮格的看法
是不是你非常非常認同這一個
不管是你的人格面具也好
你認同權威也好
那最後就是在這個部分上
你就會離你自己真實的感受越遠
你就越難去體諒別人真實的感受
而對方的那一些狀態
說不定就會變成你的陰影
有點像是這種感覺嗎
嗯
那榮格也會用情節來形容啊
特別我們剛才在講情緒的時候
就是有一塊情緒斷掉了
它脫離我的控制
然後游離在我之外
自己變成山大王或土匪了
那我是官府
所謂的自我就是官府是政
合法政府是
那這邊有一個游離的武裝分子
他經常會侵擾我
在特定世界
不管你注意的是權威
他注意的是什麼
那這些情節大大小小
他遇到合適它生長的土壤
它會突然的爆發
它會侵佔我的理智
所以
我們人有時候經常會被特定議題勾到
對 就踩到地雷就爆炸
然後你我們事後回想
會覺得很不好意思
那好像不是我或我的教養
應該表現出來的樣子
榮格心理學對這件事是非常寬容的
因為我們認為
其實當時的你並不是你
可是我們有一個道德責任
叫做我要去認識原來我之外
還有另外一個我的存在
於是我們的個體化之路就開啓了
是所以可以這樣子講
就所有你認不出來看不清楚的東西
他是
一大塊情緒
他可能就是情節
而這一大片你看不清楚的東西
可以就說是你的陰影
沒有辦法認領的
你沒有辦法接受的
他不是你
日常生活想意識的那些東西
可能就是你的陰影
因為剛剛就是鐘穎老師在講這個
榮格關於情結啊
還有對於就是剛剛說這些
就是我沒有辦法處理的情緒
我覺得跟完形好像
就那個情緒的斷裂
因為完形也會講你對這個情緒
因為某些原因
可能因為過去父母的否定
或是社會的不認同
或是總之一些原因
你壓抑了
你否定了這個情緒
他讓你跟這個情緒造成一個斷裂
之後
這一個剛剛老師講那個山大王的東西
榮格用情結
那個完形就講這就是未盡事宜
哈哈哈然後這個未盡事宜
就是會讓你只不過被插個隊
你就想揍對方
就是情緒就會突然上來
然後事後想想就會覺得說
其實我真的不用這樣
就我可以制止他
我可以叫他不要這樣子
可是我乾嘛要揍他呢
可是為什麼那個當下我要做這個事情
我覺得在有時候我在念榮格的時候
我發現他跟完形的某些東西
去感受很像
因為他們對於就是關於我們會有一些情緒
因為斷裂的關係
我們沒有辦法認領
甚至我們沒有辦法意識
然後他反而會是最容易影響我們的人
就是榮格跟完形
其實都對這個部分很寬容
不是說這個東西是錯的
而是這件事情他會影響我們
有時候我們沒有辦法意識到
但是就像鐘穎老師說的
去意識這件事情為什麼會影響我們
就會變得很重要
就偷偷廣告一下
我這一次在做那個停止內耗課
其實也是很大一個部分都在做
幫助大家去理解
這個部分對我們的影響
對所以就回到剛剛
就是鐘穎老師說
其實回到不管是榮格也好
或者是像完形
現在比較現後現代的體驗學派也好
都非常重視一件事情
就是覺察
所以我想說
覺察這部分也是這本書很大的重點
我想說
可不可以請鐘穎老師再多分享一些
榮格為什麼認為覺察這麼重要
因為榮格心理學的目標是走向完整
如果沒有覺察或體驗
其實人沒有辦法完整
嗯
人有一種避免害怕逃避去體驗的傾向
我們只想體驗幸福快樂的事物
我們不想要體驗
那些令我們失落或悲傷的事物
所以書裡面有說
榮格自己講失落為什麼重要
因為是失落才定義了我們是誰
是失落才賦予了我們人生的意義
可是我們多數時候會很害怕失落
會希望有一個時間停止器
或有一個時光機
能夠重新回到當時那個時光
我如果做了選擇 a或選擇b
活出我當時沒有活出的人生
我該如何
很多很多的失落個案
是帶著這個失落進來的
但榮格告訴你哦
你如果沒有這個失落
你是不會完整
你不能害怕它
你要去把它擁有回來
那人生中最大的失落叫做死亡
所以我們這本書有一篇
應該說有一個
很大部分其實都跟談死亡有關
嗯死亡是生命失去的另外一個半圓
當人死亡的時候
彷彿我們的生命就進入了婚禮
因為生跟死剛好對立
就好像男生跟
女生嘛死亡其實是婚禮
在神聖的婚禮中
我們得到了最終的幸福
那這個幸福本身並不是快樂
我覺得大家在追求完整
因為我知道
現在市面上很多這樣的說法
重要的不是完美
而是完整
你要知道
完整是有時候是不愉快的
經常是不愉快
但如果我們去害怕或逃避那個不愉快
將會迎來更多的不愉快
因為陰影總是會反覆的對我們敲門
因為他是我們的一部分
是他想要得到我們的認同
我們在各種神話故事
或台灣在地的傳說裡面
都可以看到
女鬼會想對你自我介紹
哈哈哈
中國的系統的故事
會用這種方式來表達
女鬼會對你自我介紹
所以你不能對女鬼不負責任哈哈
鐘穎老師在講
又是另外一個層級的東西
我不知道對於大家來說
那一個我們這一輩子最重要
其實不是在追求快樂
我不曉得大家的能不能理解這個概念
我也不曉得
我能不能真的理解這個概念
因為對我來說
我後來花了一些時間去想這件事情
我比較深的感受是
或許我想要的
我覺得人生最追求很重要
東西完整當然是很重要
但是如果要把完整這個東西是他
還是一個有點模糊的概念
所以如果對我來說
我比較能夠理解的
一個比較真實的概念
就會是清明
就是我覺得對我對我來說
我現在的人生是在追求
我可不真實的面對我的每一面
跟我的每個選擇
跟我的每個決定
但其實這個過程是很痛苦的
因為有時候你會真的必須看到一些
你不太想承認
然後你不太想讓人家知道
然後你不太想承認你有那個部分
尤其是像我們這種做
現在開始有做一些
就是目前工作
然後呢有時候大家在對你會有一些
其實會有一些投射
這投射各式各樣
比如說我可能不是本科系
所以有些人投射就會是你看
就算不是當乖乖牌一樣
可以有成功的一個狀態
然後或者是也有可能會投射
說對啦
他就是他就是從小都很會讀書
所以他才會成功啊
我就是沒有辦法
就是會有好的跟不好投射
可是不管怎麼樣
他的確都會有一個人設
那個人格面具都是在那邊的
可能不是心理師
可能是周慕姿這個人的人格面具
可是其實周慕姿這個人
是非常非常多樣化
像我最近就是比較需要去銀行辦事情
然後其實我平常都是戴口罩
所以不太就是
而且我也沒有那麼有名
所以不太會被認出來
但是呢因為
名字很特別
所以我每次簽名的時候就會被認出來
然後會有櫃員甚至經理衝出來
很大聲的說
你就是那個周慕姿心理師嗎
我都有聽你有Podcast
然後我在那個當下
都會覺得非常非常的不好意思
那個非常的不好意思
是因為我本身在一開始
平常跟人相處跟互動
看我在工作模式是很不一樣的
我後來就是認識雪莉老師之後
我覺得答得到一個答案之後
我覺得
任何事情只要得到一個理由
就覺得還可以過下去
就是那個那個雪莉老師說我是i人
所以我是那種沒辦法很很熱
就是怎麼跟人家聊
所以我通常剛開始
遇到我不熟悉的環境
跟我不熟悉的人
我都會其實我是緊張
但我以前不曉得
因為我看起來就是很自然的人
所以我不曉得原來我會緊張
後來我發現其實我會緊張
然後我就會我我緊張的方式
就是我逃避那個情緒的方式
就是讓自己看起來沒什麼表情
然後看起來比較防衛
比較冷漠
就是比較像是這樣
所以當被認出來的那個瞬間
我心裡就會非常懊悔
說剛剛應該要親切一點
或者是哎呦
真的是怎麼會
然後我就然後有時候就會覺得
啊這樣連出去外面辦個事情
都要維持工作模式這樣子
人生好艱難哦
所以我覺得那個那個
剛剛就是鐘穎老師在說
那個要能夠接納自己
就是那個完整
要能夠看見
我是先不說接納
要能夠看見自己的每個部分先不說
別人接不接受
自己要接受
我覺得都好不容易
鐘穎老師也有這樣的經驗嗎
應該說我在想
如果是有志於陰影工作或個體化
或者所謂的追求完整的朋友
應該會反覆驚艷到我
有很多我不想要接受的那一面
這件事情應該會有點辛苦
可能會持續時間非常的長
所以我在想
最後還要做的確實就是接納
那首先
我們要能夠把自己安頓在風暴的中心
我真的覺得那就是風暴
那我會想人不自主的想要逃
然後我們就要能夠坐在那張電椅上面
讓自己被電一電
這樣那個感覺就很像是
我那時候在那個停止內耗課程
有講到
那個
就是有時候我們覺得很難處理的
是承受那個很強烈情緒
因為
一旦看到那個自己不太能接受的部分
內心的內疚感啊羞愧感啊
特別是羞愧感是很容易
因為老師的書裡面有提到
很大一個部分在講這個
就是那些內疚感羞愧感
其實很容易讓我們很想要逃走
很想要用各種的防衛模式
去把它包起來
不處理
然後就是把它丟到
那個自己看不到的地方
榮格怎麼看這件事情
他會認為
我們可以用怎麼樣的態度去面對
不管是我們對自己
因為是能夠接納當然很好
但有時候我們沒有辦法
那沒有辦法時候
我要怎麼讓自己坐得下
在那個風暴的中心
我要能夠承受那個強烈情緒
榮格有沒有什麼提議哈哈哈
這個觀點其實非
常的棒因為榮格在紅書裡面
倒是說了一個關鍵字
就是接納
我覺得很特別
因為紅紅書這本書在100年前寫的
大約100年前被寫出來
但是他裡面提了一個接納
這個詞
應該在那個時代的心理學界是沒有
不存在的
沒錯因為那是後現代的心理學派
才比較常用到的字
他在深入他的內心的幻象
一些殺人的幻象裡面
後來去提到了這個詞
換句話說
他一定也深刻的驚艷到
那種很不舒服的感覺
但是我可以分享他的經歷是
當他開始接納自己
有這個殘酷的那一面的時候
他發現在最深的地方可以走到最高
自身帶來的至高
在最深的地方會引領到人的高處
人在最高處的時候
反而會走向一個低處
換句話說
他把生命或者人的經驗的感受
形容為一個圓
心裡的能量形容為一個流
這個流經常是來回往復的
此刻你可能處於低
或者陰的那一級
但是一段時間之後
他將會把你帶回去陽
帶回去這個另外的那一面
所以如果我們先能夠接受
其實生命的能量是一條來回往復的流
我們就比較能夠把自己安住
在當我在低谷的時候
生命的能量會自動就把我們帶回去
生命的高峰
我們要能夠相信
帶著這種相對主義的觀點
我就不再去欲求說
我只能永遠停留在某一個狀態
嗯對
那就不是生命的流
它其實是一個死掉的狀態
叫做我固定在高點
是固定在我人生的高峰
高山上但是他生命是會流動的
是這個真的是跟完形好像
完形很喜歡講一個東西
就是因為大家都會想改變嘛
可是又覺得很難改變
然後就更挫折
然後就覺得我都沒有辦法改變
所以完形最喜歡講的東西就是
你不改變
你知道你就開始改變了
因為你本來不知道
你現在知道了
你知道了改變就開始了
然後我發現有很多人就是覺得 天吶
完形講話更玄學
就是而且因為我現在在台灣
完形就是最長
在推動的其實是曹中瑋老師嘛
中瑋老師那個形象就感覺很神
哈哈哈神性
這樣子
但我自己的感受也是很深的感覺
就是如果用非常白話的方式去講
就是當我們今天越覺得
我硬要自己去做到什麼事情的時候
我覺得那一個推動
會讓我們那個反彈其實更明顯
那感覺就很像是我們內在的那個衝突
他就是存在的
我們就是會有很多個聲音
如果只允許一個聲音出現
其他的聲音
他會用非常令你討厭的方式出現
因為他要提醒你
那個狀態是非常非常明顯的
所以我在想
這個可能也是鐘穎老師寫這本書很大的意義
因為我覺得
在每一個我們不想要接受的東西裡面
不管是害怕犯錯羞愧感
然後或者是我是怎麼樣不想要
就是面對一些事情
自己的陰影等等
在這本書裡面都有獲得一些
我覺得不能說解答
應該算是指引
就是這些東西它可以怎麼樣被流動
然後當它可以被流動的時候
我們跟自己就會比較
就是有些人喜歡用和解啦
但是我覺得可能更接近接納
我就更能接納
比較平和的看待我身上的每個東西
讓它就在那裡
不用一定要被消失或被消滅
我覺得那是一個很很不容易的感受
我覺得那是一個很不容易的感受
我最後想要跟眾位老師討論一個東西
因為其實還是有很多想討論的
因為裡面還有一個東西在講勇氣
我也覺得很棒
但我覺得裡面還有一個東西我更有
我覺得很有意思
就是愛跟權力意志
就是那時候
就是鐘穎老師在裡面寫到
說愛跟權力意志
榮格認為這個東西是互為陰影
然後我就想到弗洛姆講的
因為弗洛姆也說嘛
就是人類就是在逃避自由
所以就是你有時候我們會為了要關係
為了要愛
就是你會自自砍手足
然後讓你自己可以獲得愛獲得關係
放棄你個人的自由意志
因為我們不相信我們可以
我們可以用我展現出我自己
跟別人溝通
讓別人理解的方式去獲得愛
我們不相信這件事情
然後那時候
因為像我們這種就是從小就是
就是一方面就一邊腹黑權威
然後一邊就是當乖小孩的人
在看到這個話很有感覺
所以我最後是不是可以請鐘穎老師
分享一下
榮格講的這一段概念
榮德說這個愛欲跟權力意志互為陰影
那大概就兩件事
其實他講的是阿德勒跟弗洛伊德
這兩個人
因為愛欲
愛欲是那個弗洛
那個弗洛伊德啊
那權力意志是阿德勒所提出來的觀念
那我們現在比較把它理解為
就是說愛跟權力
其實他是對人為他對人是同樣重要的
那可是很特別的是
當人在愛中的時候
當人沒有把愛活出來的時候
他就會使用權力來獲得它
那對一個經常使用權力的人來說
他可能要的其實只是愛
那我們在關係裡面其實可以看得很清楚
特別是親子關係
當我們想要去改變孩子
或是在一般的戀愛的關係裡面
熱戀期的時候
你都不會想改變對方
因為你對他有一個很充分的愛啊
某種程度可以這麼說
但是在熱戀期消失的時候
當我們看到對方的某些優點
突然變成了缺點
你就會想要去改變他
換句話說
這時候權力
已經悄悄的溜進了我們的關係裡面
所以愛跟權力
經常處於一個相互解抗的現象
某種程度是這樣
他才會說愛跟權力互為陰影
如果如果您認同了這句話
那我們現在就可以看
以後在關係中
當我希望對方改變的時候
你看就可以思考現在是愛在說話
還是我內心的權力在說話
我覺得這個東西真的是講的太好了
因為不知道為什麼
我一直冒出那個捷運的那個事情
因為我那時候第一次在看捷運
那個事情的時候
我第一
因為我我自己用我自己的習慣的看事
情的方式就是我就會
我就會覺得說
所以這個阿姨
她基本來說就是想要掌控啊
他希望所有的狀況
所有的情況
他都是要被重視的
被掌控的
所有的東西
他要有特權
他要被在意
他要被注意
所以只要今天這個狀況他不能掌控
他就一定要掌控
即使他不一定那麼需要那個東西
可是對他來說
只要他一能掌控
他就贏了
然後對他來講這個贏就是很重要
所以我那時候很快速的就是這樣理解
可是如果對應到鐘穎老師說
我這個東西
他想要的其實是愛啊
哈哈哈
當你把那一份權利掌控的權利讓給我
我就會覺得我被愛
是我就覺得我被重視了
對我就覺得你看我被在意了
我被重視了
那就是愛啊
所以他想要其實被愛對
但是用了很討人厭的方法對
然後非常長
我們在遇到很多權威
遇到很多父母
或是跟伴侶之間的關係
我們其實會感受到都是這些
就是他其實想要的是愛
是注意但他用的東西是權力意志
是壓迫是改變你
然後你就會覺得非常痛苦
而他用這個方式你還想要
你就會想要離他更遠
他就更得不到愛
他就更想要壓迫你控制你
就情緒勒索
哈哈哈然後這個東西
就會一直重復的一個出現
重復的一直出現
我覺得這真的是太有趣了
好的那麼最後我想要請鐘穎老師
可不可以再跟我們
因為畢竟這本書對鐘穎老師來說
就是我個人覺得應該是
也因為蠻特別的
就是我很少看你寫這樣子的東西
就是因為你大部分都是分析故事
這本書我覺得有一點像是某方面來說
我覺得很像是一個指引
就是很多人面對生活的衝突困境
自我的懷疑
想要去探索內在
可是完全不知道怎麼走的時候
有一個像是就是地圖書
然後讓大家可以按圖索引的
去摸索自己
那我可不可以請鐘穎老師
在最後跟大家分享一下
這本書
你最想帶給大家的東西是什麼
這本書其實會出現是有一點點意外
因為今年是榮格去世的150週年
那我在想
是不是利用榮格去世的150週年
能夠在台灣用中文的方式
寫一本我們比較全面性的
好全面性的去碰到
他曾經關注到的每一個議題
其實他關注的議題非常的廣
那市面上有時候我們討論的書的時候
是從單一的面相去下去
好那
既然有那麼越來越多的人在引用榮格
越來越多人在好奇榮格
所以我想或許我們可以有一本書來
全面性的來談他
但他其實宗旨只有一個
就是書名
活出你的本來面目嗯
這個書名最重要部分就是
深刻的認識你自己
深刻的
它不是一句雞湯
它其實是一個很嚴格的
我覺得很嚴格
那也是一個非常漫長的一個考驗
所有曾經犯過錯的朋友們
歡迎你來打開這本書
因為這本書不是給不會犯錯的人讀的
是犯錯才讓我們成為英雄
這是英雄之旅的第一個考驗
你犯錯然後你下地獄
哈哈 進了冥府
也就說你進入你的陰影
去瞭解你陰影中藏著什麼東西
你才可能活出你的本來面目
所以我要說
這本書是給所有在受苦中的人讀的
最後我就跟著鐘穎老師說的這句話
然後延伸一個我最近看的一本書
裡面講到一句話
我覺得對應起來超有道理
上面寫完美主義
是極度害怕的人會選擇的生存策略
哇我真的是覺得這簡直這個共識性
你知道這本書我今天早上才看
然後剛好我們今天就聊到這件事
我覺得這就是共識性啊各位
所以這一個鐘穎老師這本書
活出你的本來面目
非常非常精彩
我個人很喜歡
對我的幫助也很大
所以如果對榮格心理學有興趣的朋友
但是你有時候又覺得榮格那紅書
我根本看不下去
然後覺得很難的時候
我很鼓勵大家
可以先從這本書就是開始
讓自己可以離榮格近一點啊
我覺得這一個榮格
他是一個幫助我們去瞭解自己
認識自己
一個非常非常棒的學派
所以分享給大家
先預祝鐘穎老師新書大賣
＜活出你的本來面目＞
好的那周慕姿放心說
我們下次見嘍
掰掰